THE ROLL PLEASE [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible] EIGHT BELL
[inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
THEY'RE ALSO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible] FOR TITLE
[inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible] FOR LOCKE
[inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NELSON [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
WHY CASSIE [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE.
WE WILL BE LEAD IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY OUR CHAPLAIN SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WE WILL
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE BY TO THE FLAG.
BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
LET US CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE --
GODS WHO WEEP SAID FRACTURED
LIVES.
IN SPIRALS TO HEAL THE HURTING.
HELP US TO SEAL THE CRACKS
CREATED BY OUR COMPLICITY IN
FAILING TO LOVE.
MAY OUR WORDS AND ACTIONS SPEAK
LOVE AND NOT COMPLACENCY.
MAY WE CHOOSE LOVE WHEN FACED
WITH MINDLESS HATE.
LOVE WHEN FACED WITH RETALIATION.
LOVE WHEN TEMPTED BY DECEPTION.
LOVE WHEN ADDRESSING THE ISSUES
OF OUR TIME.
MAY WE CHOOSE LOVE WHEN FACING
RACISM SEXISM HETEROSEXISM.
XENOPHOBIA.
IN ALL THOSE WE DO.
AND ALL THOSE WE SAY.
AND IN ALL THE PLACES WE GO.
MAY WE CHOOSE LOVE.
AND DEMONSTRATE OUR LOVE WITH
ACTION AMEN.
PLEASE JOIN ME.
WHY DON'T WAITED [inaudible]
HI OF AMERICA AND TO THE
REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT STANDS ONE
NATION UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL [inaudible]
AND MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
SENATOR PAN. FOR YOU PROPHETIC
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
SENATORS I AM THRILLED TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO KNOWLEDGE A
VERY SPECIAL GROUP OF STUDENT
PASSENGERS FROM ASAKA JAPAN WHO
ARE IN THE GALLERY HERE TODAY --
THESE STUDENTS ARE PARTICIPATING
IN THE CALIFORNIA JAPAN SCHOLARS
PROGRAM AND EDUCATIONAL EXCHANGE
INITIATED.
IN THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
THAT'S BEEN RUNNING FOR TWENTY
TWO YEARS.
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
INTERNATIONAL RELATIONS
FOUNDATION THIS PROGRAM WAS THE
FIRST EVER STATE SPONSORED HIGH
SCHOOL EXCHANGE.
THIS YEAR WE HAVE TWENTY NINE
STUDENTS FROM A SOCK --
THEY'RE STAYING WITH HOST
FAMILIES IN THE OAK GROVE CHECK
FOR TWO WEEKS TO LEARN ABOUT
CALIFORNIA'S PEOPLE CULTURE.
IT CERTAINLY TAKES COURAGE AND A
CURIOUS MIND TO TRAVEL SO FAR
FROM HOME AT A YOUNG AGE THIS
YOUNG AGE.
I'M SURE THIS EXPERIENCE PROVIDE
LASTING BENEFITSIN TERMS OF
PERSONAL GROWTH MUTUAL
UNDERSTANDING AND FRIENDSHIP.
THE STUDENTS ARE COMPANY BY TWO
TEACHER CHAPERONES FROM ASAKA
INTO JAPANESE LANGUAGE TEACHERS
FROM ELK GROVE.
THESE AMAZING EDUCATORS
VOLUNTEER THEIR TIME TO DEVELOP
THEIR STUDENTS BEYOND THE
CLASSROOM.
THIS IS THE KIND OF COMMITMENT
THAT MAKES A DIFFERENCE IN
STUDENTS LIVES PLEASE JOIN ME IN
COMMENDING THE STUDENT BASS
CENTERS DEDICATED TEACHERS
EXTENDING A WARM SENATE WELCOME
THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA SENATE
[inaudible]
SENATOR MITCHELL.
UNDER PRIVILEGES ON THE FLOOR IF
I MAY YES TO ME THANK YOU I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE --
FROM THE SEVERAL AREA FROM
ACKNOWLEDGING THE PROGRAM I HAD
THE PRIVILEGE WITH SOME OF MY
OTHER COLLEAGUES HERE.
IN THE SENATE TO TRAVEL --
TO JAPAN AS A PART OF THE
OFFICIAL SENATE INTERNATIONAL
OFFICE OF TRAVEL.
A YEAR AGO.
HE TO TWO YEARS AGO.
ON AND MET WITH CURRENT ELECTED
LEADERS IN OSAKA.
SEVERAL OF WHOM HAD PARTICIPATED
IN THE PROGRAM AND SO WE WERE
ABLE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THEIR EXPERIENCE LIVING IN ELK
GROVE -- AND
SO -- HOW
WONDERFUL FOR YOU ALL TO BE ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE AND WE SHOULD
KNOW THAT THEIR EXPERIENCE HERE?
IN THE SACRAMENTO REGION REALLY
HELPS INFORM MANY OF THEIR
LEADERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES IN
POLICY MAKING WHEN THEY RETURN
HOME US WE MET AGAIN WITH
ELECTED LEADERS IN OSAKA WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM SO
AGAIN WELCOME.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR AMBERG ON THIS ITEM.
SENATOR PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU ARE MADAM PRESIDENT A
MEMBERS IT'S MY PLEASURE TO
INTRODUCE FROM THE GALLERY AND
THEY CAN STAND UP.
FOR STUDENTS FROM PASADENA HIGH
SCHOOL IN MARSHALL FUNDAMENTAL
AND THE CITY OF PASADENA WHO ARE
HERE ADVOCATING ON TOBACCO USE
AND YOUTH AND SO I WANT TO GIVE
A BIG SHOUT OUT TO THE PASADENA
STOMPERS.
WARM WELCOME TO PASADENA.
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
MEMBERS MOVING ON TO MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION JOINT
RULE SIXTY TWO A WILL BE WAIVED
FOR THE ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE. TO
MEET TOMORROW WITHOUT FOUR DAYS
NOTICE IN THE DAILY FILE
[inaudible]
SENATOR UMBERG.
THE THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM EIGHTY
TWO S. C. R. SEVEN FROM THE
INACTIVE FILE [inaudible]
SO ORDERED.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE.
SECOND READING FILE.
ITEMS.
ONE TWO THREE SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTEEN SENATE BILL TO A FOR THE
MOMENTS AND SENATE BILL FIFTY
EIGHT WITH A MINUTES.
THE NEXT ITEM IS THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
WE MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS FOR A
CHECK UP FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
WHICH IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
SERRA MEGAN'S FOR THE
APPOINTMENT TO THE OFF HIGHWAY
MOTOR VEHICLE RECREATION
COMMISSION.
MISS --
MEGAN'S IS THAT CALIFORNIA STATE
DIRECTOR OF THE AMERICAN
CONSERVATION EXPERIENCE SHE WAS
APPROVED BY UNANIMOUS VOTE IN
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON FEBRUARY
TWENTIETH.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM [inaudible]
SENATOR GLACIER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
WELCOME TO THE DAY AFTER DOING A
FANTASTIC JOB OF THEY'RE NOT
GONNA ASK ANY TOUGH RULES
QUESTIONS OF AN HOLD OFF ON THAT.
BUT I DID WANT TO SPEAK ABOUT
THE APPOINTMENT OF THIS MEGAN'S
TO THIS BOARD I DID HAVE THE
CHANCE TO SPEAK WITH HER.
EARLIER THIS MONTH AND I HM IT'S
IN TRYING TO FIND BALANCE IN
THIS WORLD OF OFF.
HIGHWAY VEHICLE ACTIVITY --
I THINK IT'S THE TYPE OF FIVE
THOUGHTFUL ENGAGEMENT THAT WOULD
WANT FROM SOMEBODY.
ON THIS COMMISSION AND I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT HER.
NOMINATION TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY MORE COMMENT --
DO MADE UP THE DEBATE ON THIS
APPOINTMENT.
SEEING NONE THE ROLE PLEASE.
ALLEN.
HI.
ARCHULETA.
HI ATKINS. FIVE EIGHT HI BILL.
I BOARD JUST.
BY BRADFORD.
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
HI CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
HI DORADO.
BY GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
AYE GROWTH.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE
[inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
HI LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
I'M MORE LOCK.
I'M REAL [inaudible]
BY NIELSEN.
BY PM.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
I AM BURKE.
HI WHAT CASKEY [inaudible]
I WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI.
ICE THIRTY SIX KNOWS ZEROS THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
ON FILE.
SENATOR WORK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT IN
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF PATRICIA
ARENA FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE OFF
HIGHWAY MOTOR VEHICLE RECREATION
COMMISSION.
MR RAIN IS A RECREATION
SUPERVISOR AT THE CITY OF EL
CENTRO COMMUNITY SERVICES
DEPARTMENT.
SHE WAS A APPROVED BY UNANIMOUS
VOTE BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON
FEBRUARY TWENTIETH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY COMMENTS OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM [inaudible]
SAME.
NINE THE ROW PLEASE [inaudible]
ALLEN.
BY ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
I BILL.
HI PORGES [inaudible]
I BRADFORD [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
HI DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I WAS SO.
HI -- TITLE
[inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
HI JONES [inaudible]
HI LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I'M REAL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
BY PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
[inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
HI STONE [inaudible]
BY AMBER [inaudible]
OUR COUNTY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
BY WILK [inaudible]
HI.
CALL THE ABSENTEES PLEASE
[inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH SKINNER [inaudible]
WHY CASKEY? THIRTY THREE EYES
NOSE ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
SENATE THIRD READING
[inaudible]
DOCTOR PAN.
A FILE ITEM.
NINE SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY BY SENATOR PAN RELATIVE
TO BLEEDING DISORDERS AWARENESS
MONTH.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS I RISE TODAY PERCENT
STR TWENTY WHICH RECOGNIZES
MARCH TWENTY NINETEEN IS
BLEEDING DISORDERS AWARENESS
MONTH.
HEMOPHILIA IS A RARE GENETIC
CONDITION THAT AFFECTS AT LEAST
FOUR THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA AND VAUGHAN BILLER
BAND DISEASE IMPACTS AT LEAST
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA --
MOST OF US --
PERHAPS LEARN SOMETHING ABOUT
HEMOPHILIA AS WE STUDY THE
HISTORY OF QUEEN VICTORIA AND
HER FAMILY.
BUT THIS IS A DISEASE THAT
AFFECTS PEOPLE FROM ALL
BACKGROUNDS NOT JUST ROYALTY.
WITHOUT PROPER TREATMENT PEOPLE
WITHOUT HEMOPHILIA AND OTHER
RELATED BLEEDING DISORDERS OFTEN
FACE SPONTANEOUS BLEEDING
EPISODES INTO JOINTS MUSCLES
INTERNAL ORGANS AND EVEN THEIR
BRAIN.
WHICH CAN THEN LEAD TO FREQUENT
HOSPITAL VISITS CHRONIC PAIN
PERMIT DISABILITY AND FORTY
SOMETIMES CAN EVEN BE FATAL.
HOWEVER WITH PROPER CARE AND
ACCESS TO CONFERENCE OF MEDICAL
ATTENTION PEOPLE THIS RARE
CONDITION CAN CONTROL THE
BLEEDING EPISODES AND ARE ABLE
TO LEAVE FULL PRODUCTIVE LIVES.
THIS AWARENESS MONTH WILL LEAD
TO GREATER UNDERSTANDING OF NOT
JUST HEMOPHILIA BUT ALL
INHERITABLE BLEEDING DISORDERS.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
FIRMLY COMMITTED TO THE PROPER
CARE TREATMENT OF ALL CHILDREN
AND ADULTS WERE BATTLING THIS
CONDITION ON A DAILY BASIS.
WHOSE MEMBERS ESPECIALLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION
THANK YOU. FOR ANY COMMENT WORK
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM
[inaudible]
SAYING.
NINE MEMBERS.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
TO TO APPLYING THE UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL [inaudible]
THING.
NINE ICE THIRTY SIX NO.
ZERO RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS MOVING RETURNING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
NOW IS THE TIME TO FOR THE
ADJOURNMENT MEMORIES
[inaudible]
SENATOR JACKSON'S.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU
ALL TO JOIN ME.
IN A CHURNING IN THE MEMORY OF A
TRULY GREAT AMERICAN.
NAY BIRCH BY.
SOME OF US OLDER FOLKS REMEMBER
HIM AND NOT HIS SON EVAN BY WHO
SUCCEEDED HIM.
IN THE UNITED STATES SENATE.
IF I COULD GET THE ATTENTION OF
MY COLLEAGUES PLEASE.
BIRCH BY WAS TRULY AN
EXTRAORDINARY LEGISLATOR AND
UNITED STATES SENATOR WHO WAS
RESPONSIBLE. FOR SOME OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT LEGISLATION THAT
WE HAVE SEEN IN THE MODERN
AMERICAN ERA.
STARTING WITH MY PERSONAL
FAVORITE TITLE NINE HE WAS
ACTUALLY THE CHIEF ARCHITECT OF
TITLE NINE WHICH PASSED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO GIVING
WOMEN THE RIGHT TO COMPETE
EQUALLY IN EDUCATION AND IN
SPORTS.
AND HIS LEGACY NOW IS REFLECTED
IN THE EXTRAORDINARY
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE SEE IN OUR
DAUGHTERS AND OUR SISTERS AND IN
SOME INSTANCES.
OUR MOTHERS WHO HAVE NOW BEEN
GIVEN THE CHANCE.
TO PARTICIPATE IN IN LIFE ON AN
EQUAL FOOTING WHEN IT COMES TO
EDUCATION.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE WORKPLACE
HE KNOWS EDUCATION WAS GOING TO
BE THE MOST CRITICAL COMPONENT
TO OPENING THE DOOR FOR QUALITY
FOR WOMEN?
AND HE WAS ABLE TO GET THIS
MEASURE PASSED IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO IT CAME AT
A TIME WHEN WOMEN EARN FEWER
THAN 10% OF ALL MEDICAL AND LAW
DEGREES AND FEWER THAN THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND HIGH SCHOOL
GIRLS ONE IN.
TWENTY SEVEN PLAYED SPORTS.
FAST FORWARD TODAY WE REALIZE
THAT THERE ARE MORE WOMEN
GRADUATING COLLEGE THAN MEN AND
ONE OUT OF EVERY TWO YOUNG WOMEN.
PARTICIPATES IN EITHER HIGH
SCHOOL OR COLLEGE SPORTS AN
EXTRAORDINARY ACCOMPLISHMENT BUT
IN ADDITION TO THAT HE WAS ONE
OF THE LEADING PROPONENTS. FOR
THE EQUAL RIGHTS AMENDMENT.
HE ALSO WAS THE PRINCIPAL
ARCHITECT FOR BOTH THE TWENTY
FIFTH AND TWENTY SIX THE MEMONS
TO THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION THE TWENTY FIFTH
PLANNING FOR SUCCESSION AFTER A
PRESIDENT --
HAS LEFT OFFICE IN THIS CASE IT
WAS AFTER THE ASSASSINATION OF
JOHN F. KENNEDY.
THE POSITIONOF VICE PRESIDENT
WHEN VACANT FOR A YEAR UNTIL THE
TWENTY FIFTH AMENDMENT WAS
PRESENTED AND PASSED AND OF
COURSE THE TWENTY SIXTH
AMENDMENT WHICH PROVIDED THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
TO VOTE AT THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN
DURING THAT PERIOD OF TIME WE
HAD THE VERY CONTENTIOUS.
VIETNAM WAR WHERE WE WERE
SENDING PRIMARILY OUR YOUNG MEN
OVERSEAS TO FIGHT A WAR WHEN
THEY WERE EIGHTEEN AND YET THEY
COULD HAVE NO SAY IN THE
ELECTORAL PROCESS UNTIL THEY
WERE TWENTY ONE HE WAS THE
PRINCIPAL ARCHITECT. FOR
CHANGING THAT SO THAT NOW YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO VOTE AT THE
AGE OF EIGHTEEN HE WAS AN
EXTRAORDINARY MAN SERVED
EIGHTEEN YEARS --
IN I BELIEVE IT WAS EIGHTEEN
YEARS FROM NINETEEN SIXTY THREE
TO NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE IN THE
UNITED STATES SENATE AND IN FACT
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO HE WAS
CONSIDERING A RUN. FOR PRESIDENT.
BUT HIS BREAST CANCER AND HE
CHOSE NOT TO TO DO THAT BUT HIS
LEGACY WILL LIVE.
IN THE ANNALS OF OUR COUNTRY WE
ARE VERY GRATEFUL FOR PEOPLE
LIKE BIRCH BY TO HAVE SERVED HIS
COUNTRY TO OF RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF EQUALITY FOR ALL.
TO RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
MAKING SURE THAT THIS COUNTRY
WAS ON A COURSE WHERE ALL PEOPLE
WOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO A
QUALITY.
AND SO IT IS WITH BOTH A HEAVY
HEART AND A DEGREE OF ENORMOUS
APPRECIATION THAT I ASKED THAT
WE IN TURN IN THE MEMORY OF
SENATOR BIRCH BY OF INDIANA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE PASS
OUR CONDOLENCES TO THE BOB
FAMILY FOR THAT --
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY [inaudible]
SENATOR BELL.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AS I'D
LIKE TO A RISE AND TO MAKE A
MOTION AND A JOURNEY MEMORY OF
ROBERT C<c.cyan>.</c>
ROBERT WAS --
CIVIL RIGHTS ACTIVISTS IN
SILICON VALLEY --
HE MOVED INTO SILICON VALLEY --
FROM --
HONOLULU HAWAII.
AND ROBERT WAS THE YOUNGEST OF
TEN CHILDREN --
SO THAT WE HAD THAT IN COMMON.
THAT I WAS --
A FAMILY OF TEN ALSO.
HE CAME TO CALIFORNIA TO ATTEND
COMPTON COLLEGE AND SOUND OF THE
UNIVERSITY SERVED IN THE US ARMY.
AND THEN WORK FOR THE VETERANS
ADMINISTRATION.
AND HIGH TECH COMPANIES.
WHAT DISTINGUISHES ROBERT WAS?
THE TIME THAT HE STOOD UP TO
DISCRIMINATION.
AND THAT HE TRAINED PEOPLE.
IN HIS OCCUPATION AS A PERSONNEL
MANAGER.
TRAIN PEOPLE AND AT THE SAME
TIME.
HAD THE PEOPLE HE TRAINED --
GET PROMOTED OVER HIM.
AND ONE OF THE REASONS WAS DUE
TO HIS ACCENT THAT HE HAD --
AND THE DISCRIMINATION THAT HE
RECEIVES --
INVIGORATED AND ACTIVATED --
MANY PEOPLE AND SO. TO CREATE AN
ORGANIZATION CALLED --
ASIAN AMERICANS FOR COMMUNITY
INVOLVEMENT.
ASIAN AMERICANS COMMUNITY
INVOLVEMENT WAS A CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION DESIGNED TO BREAK
THE GLASS CEILINGS BUT
DISCRIMINATION.
THAT OCCURRED --
TWO CASES LIKE ROBBER CAM.
AND RUBBER CAM WAS ONE OF THE
ORIGINAL FOUNDERS OF ASIAN
AMERICANS FOR COMMUNITY
INVOLVEMENT HE WON HIS LAWSUIT.
AND BROKE THE GLASS CEILING --
BROKE THE DISCRIMINATION.
THAT EXISTED.
IN SILICON VALLEY.
OF FOR ASIAN AMERICANS AND
OTHERS --
BASED ON ON ON THEIR ACCENT OR
OTHER KINDS OF DISCRIMINATORY --
ELEMENTS SO ROBERT TâM.
WAS A TREND SETTER.
TODAY THE ASIAN AMERICANS OR
COMMITTEE INVOLVEMENT.
THE NOW PROVIDE SERVICES IN OUR
COMMUNITY CIVIL RIGHTS SERVICES
AS WELL AS HEALTH SERVICES. FOR
OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE.
IN TERMS OF THE HEALTH CARE AND
OTHER SERVICES FOR ASIAN
AMERICANS IN SILICON VALLEY.
WE WOULD LIKE --
TO A JOURNEY IN ROBERT'S MEMORY.
AS PART OF HIS ACTION TEAM WHEN --
THE LAWSUIT TOOK PLACE HE HAD A
YOUNG.
STUDENT AT SAN JOSE STATE.
WHO IS NOW A STATE SENATOR?
SERVING ON HIS ACTION TEAM.
FIGHTING THE DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST ROBERT AND ALWAYS
REMEMBER.
THE MEETINGS ARE CHURNING THAT
WE HAD ON THE THE LAWSUIT.
AND ROBERT PULLING OUT HIS
GUITAR OR UKULELE IN SINGING THE
HAWAIIAN SONG SO BEAUTIFUL ONE
SONGS ALOHA ROBERT.
PLEASE PASS OUR CONDOLENCES TO
THE KH FAMILY.
AS WE JOURNEY IN HIS MEMORY.
IS THERE ANY OTHER BUSINESS TO
COME BEFORE THIS HOUSE
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS
SENATOR ATKINS THE DESK IS CLEAR.
Q. MADAM PRESIDENT.
AND HAPPY BEGINNING OF THE WEEK
TO EVERYONE I WANTED TO REMIND
FOLKS THAT TOMORROW.
WE WILL BE HOSTING THE STATED
THE JUDICIARY IF PEOPLE COULD BE
HERE AT TEN FORTY FIVE WILL BE
JOINED BY.
THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR WHO IS
THE PRESIDENT --
WE WILL BE JOINED BY OUR
GOVERNOR AND SO I THINK IT WOULD
BE WONDERFUL IF WE COULD BE HERE
ON TIME READY TO RECEIVE THEM.
AND WANTED TO JUST REMIND YOU OF
THAT I KNOW WE HAVE A LONG WE
GET HEAD OF US WE WILL SEE YOU
TOMORROW --
HOPEFULLY HERE AT TEN FORTY FIVE
AND THEN WE WILL RECONVENE --
THURSDAY THE TWENTY FIRST MARCH
TWENTY FIRST AT NINE AM THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
SENATOR GALGIANI FOR WHAT
PURPOSE DO RISE. TO ANNOUNCE AG
DAY ON WEDNESDAY OF THIS WEEK.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU I WANTED TO ANNOUNCE
THAT WEDNESDAY MARCH TWENTIETH
IS CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE DAY AT
THE STATE CAPITOL.
AND THIS YEAR WE WILL BE
CELEBRATING ONE HUNDRED YEARS OF
AD PRODUCTION IN THE STATE.
THE STATE WILL ALLOW RANCHERS
FARMERS STATE LEGISLATORS AND
GOVERNMENT LEADERS AND THE
PUBLIC TO RECOGNIZE THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF AG IN OUR LIVES
IN HONOR THOSE INVOLVED.
IN AGRICULTURE FOR THEIR HARD
WORK AND DEDICATION TO FEED THE
NATION AND THE WORLD I HOPE
YOU'LL JOIN US THIS WEDNESDAY.
THERE WILL BE FOOD FLOWERS AND
ANIMALS TO BAT AND THE EVENT
STARTS AT ELEVEN THIRTY BUT
LEGISLATORS AND STAFF CAN JOIN
US AT TEN THIRTY THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH SENATOR PAN FOR WHAT
PURPOSE DO YOU WRITE --
IT'S COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENT.
YOU MAY PROCEED THE JOINTS
SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE ON THE
TWENTY TWENTY U. S. CENSUS AND
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON THE
TWENTY TWENTY U. S. CENSUS WILL
BE HOLDING ITS HEARING AT THREE
THIRTY PM.
ROOM FORTY TWO A TWO TODAY THANK
YOU.
SEEING NO OTHER MY KEPT MIKE'S
UP THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY THIS
AFTERNOON AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE.
WE WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY AT
NINE AM